this is opte tune he's a turkish
trichologist and right now you are
watching him conduct a follicular unit
extraction procedure or more
specifically a direct hair implantation
technique on a patient that is
experiencing hair loss
okay wow that was a mouthful you may be
asking what is a trichologist and why
does all of this look like something out
of a sci-fi movie
don't worry i got you worldwide about
sixty percent of men and forty percent
of women experience hair loss as they
age
fortunately there are several
over-the-counter and non-invasive
surgical remedies a trichologist like
octay is a specialist who studies
diseases or problems related to the hair
and scalp and often recommends treatment
the most popular hair transplant
operation conducted today is called fue
or follicular unit extraction
in this operation a surgeon uses micro
punch tools to remove individual hair
follicles from a healthier region of the
scalp and move them over to an area of
the scalp where the hair is thinner or
even absent
usually the fue method requires an
incision but the more innovative dhi or
direct hair implantation technique seen
in this video removes the need for any
incision
[Music]
the procedure is usually completed in
multiple two to four hour sessions over
the course of several days and then
voila hair transplanted into a new area
of your scalp typically begins growing
back in about three to four months yay
you